[Music]
that was loud
goodness gracious I missed you all
terribly while Riverdale was on
Thanksgiving break so to celebrate our
reunion I thought we'd make today's
sweet water secrets a special live
episode start sending in your questions
and comments to me about how you're
feeling about Riverdale season three so
far and we can try and piece together
all this Griffin's and gargoyles
craziness together as always I'm your
HBIC host Leon Aguilera and this is your
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 306 chapter 41 Manhunter not
only will I be taking a look back at
your hisses and kisses from the last
episode
I'll also be breaking down the 306 promo
teasing you with my three clues and
answering a flurry of questions that
you're gonna be sending me live right
now ask me whatever you want
there's no nothing's off-limits now to
top it all off I'm also bringing you a
very magical interview with Lilly
Reinhardt giving her enchanting thoughts
on the chilling Adventures of Sabrina so
get excited for that but first let's
take a look back at your cutest and
Caddy's comments about episode 305
chapter 40 The Great Escape in your
kisses and kisses now kicking things off
with some romance thoughts read mind
films commented kisses to Tony for
totally initiating and dominating that
sweet show knee kiss yes I agree it was
so sweet but it looks like your angel
agreed with me over the fact that this
was way too short for it to be the first
kiss of the season because they wrote
number one I think all Joni shippers are
pissed and number two kisses to the
writers this episode had everyone Cheryl
Toni sweet pea
bangs Kevin Josie Reggie it was also
enjoyable to watch them all not only the
core for yes I loved it when the entire
Riverdale group was all together in the
bunker although who else thought it was
weird when Veronica said that that group
was the only
one who knew about the bunkers existence
what about Ethel but seriously though
where did Eiffel go did the guard
walking snatch her up with his little
Twiggy arms moving on life of brownie
posted kisses to Veronica for slaying in
that blonde wig and fancy clothes and
also kisses to Betty and Kevin if we're
looking amazing on the motorcycle with
their serpent jackets agreed and LML VC
said hisses to Reggie's dad for hitting
him I just wanted to cry I know right
that just broke my heart
now here's a not so fun fact for you
guys we're actually gonna meet Reggie's
dad in episode 306 his name is Marty
mantle and he's a smarmy douche and our
Betty Cooper of the week aka our fan
with the theories who like dominated the
comments with her top theories goes to
Lauren B who left two really
thought-provoking comments Lauren B's
first comments said quote what if
Joaquin kissing Archie before ascending
relates to Ethel kissing Jughead maybe
the kiss means more than we think
mm-hmm I think you're on to something
girl and it seems like you're on a roll
cuz Lauren B also posted in episode 3
Alice says you don't just meet Edgar
there are certain levels you need to
attain then in Episode four Jughead says
The Gargoyle King yeah I'm only at level
three but it's only a matter of time
before I send to the next level and then
I get to meet him I wonder if ever and
ever is the gargoyle King but possibly
just another red herring
well done Lauren now only time will tell
if I can tell you if you're right but I
can tell you that you'll be seeing a lot
of red herrings in episode 306 so with
that all ministy 'z let's take a look at
the promo for chapter 41 Manhunter roll
it I saw there are others it locates
disciples
I don't think I can go back to Riverdale
how far do you think you're gonna get
someone's sending us a message
this symbol does it mean sacrifice
too late don't you make me say goodbye
to your challengers all of the secrets
and now okay that was a lot to digest so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
break this down and take a look at the
few key frames that we need to pay
attention to now first up Jughead was
describing a group and said that it
looked like the gargoyle king's
disciples and we see them all wearing
these rubber gargoyle masks now I still
have no idea what's going on here but
how many gangs and cult groups are in
Riverdale so far the only group I want
to join are the river vixens and the
serpents okay I'll join them all next up
we see Josie having some kind of fit and
I'm not legally allowed to tell you what
it is and what's happening here but come
on guys you got this then var Chi is
sharing a tearful phone call and V tells
her redheaded boo don't you make me say
goodbye to you Archie Andrews all I'm
gonna say is you guys have your tissues
ready and lastly I want to focus on the
fact that the gargoyle King is in the
Cooper house you guys he's in their
house you know they really should get a
dog or a better security system or
something cuz that Twiggy weirdo got in
their house is your brain tingling good
because I'm about to test your snooping
skills even more with my three clues
about episode 306 here we go all right
number one step aside Breakfast Club
Riverdale is paying homage to another
iconic film this week and this one's
killer number two daddy's little girl
has learned some key skills from her
blonde bestie but will it be enough to
save the day and number three one may
stumble but four will fall now normally
at this point in our Sweetwater previews
I'd say Tata until next time but since
we're doing a special live episode this
week we're gonna keep the fun going now
in just a second I'll be reading off
your River babe comments and questions
there are so many right now I'm so
excited but first I got a spellbinding
goody for you when I caught up with star
Lily Reinhart in October I asked her to
spill the witches brew on one of my
favorite chilling Adventures of Sabrina
twists take a look at what she told me
in the chili adventures of Sabrina
graphic novels Veronica and Betty ER
witches yeah did you ever think that
maybe you would want to tap into that
magical side I feel like I wouldn't want
to blur the lines between Riverdale and
Sabrina just like it doesn't make sense
yet because there hasn't been magic in
our show so why would there be now I
think they are very much different
universes I think it would have to be a
very special occasion for there to be a
crossover some sort of musical episode I
don't know as a Halloween episode sure
maybe a Babel in it I don't know I just
think you know there's not witchcraft in
Riverdale that I know of there's no
magic there so it's hard for me to
imagine how there would it be a
crossover but we'll see Roberto wants to
do one eventually I think again maybe
that would just be very much down the
line what do you think river babes did
you know that in the Sabrina graphic
novels that Betty and Veronica were
embracing their witchy side sidenote
read them they're fantastic and would
you guys like to see it the magic cross
over into Riverdale bewitch me with your
thoughts and now I want to take a look
at what you guys have been telling me
during this live I've been getting so
many comments right now I'm so excited
all right we're just gonna start off
Ryan says although I ship var Chi I'm
kind of glad if they break up tonight
because maybe Shoni will get more screen
time I hear what you're saying I'm not a
fan of putting down one ship in order to
love other ships I would just like maybe
more equal time for all of them but I
understand I feel like Shoni has been
extremely underrepresented this season
and I'm getting kind of peeved in a
polite way but I think it's time that we
get to see more of them a lot of folks
are just saying that they want bug-head
preach to the choir girls Kali says we
need more Shoni so much show do you love
in here let's read them all Chelsea what
episode will have the most show knee I
can't tell you but hopefully it's coming
soon Jordan barchi is most likely
endgame tonight meaning endgame in the
future or that they end their games
tonight Judith says hey sis - everything
that Hyrum owns nothing good happens
with him yes and at one point in this
tonight's episode
he says I have a job to get to what job
do you have to get to Hiram I have no
idea what you actually do Felicia says
what do you think about the picture
Roberto posted with the grave on Betty's
bed
could it be FP because he does because
doesn't he sneak into the room in this
episode Lily posted a photo a couple
months ago you guys are the best
snoopers ever and you notice everything
and I can't comment on anything you've
just said but I just want to praise you
guys for noticing everything lava turtle
to 164 says I want Cheryl Tony and
Veronica to team up to break buddy out
of Sisters of quiet Mercy I don't know
talking about Catherine says what do you
think about the current phallus
situation there was a theory that we
didn't get a kiss up until now because
it's not a romantic relationship but
will be later and then they will kiss
okay so here's what I think about the
current phallus relationship I adore
them so much and I think that Mei Chen
and skeet as actors have such an amazing
chemistry and they were the ones who
were really pushing for them to be
together on screen so I think that it's
gonna happen but there are just so many
couples on the show right now that
they're letting it be organic we got to
see that flashback kiss in our iconic
Breakfast Club episode granted that was
Lilly and Cole playing them but I liked
that we know that the passion and the
love is there but I'm really enjoying
just seeing them hug and really showing
that they do have that passion without
having to constantly see them kiss I
don't know for some reason it's just
nice for me right now
let's see Chris I think says why did
they post the episode 7 promo and what
will happen with Betty getting in the
sisters of quiet mercy did they post the
episode 7 promo
is that where what's making you guys
think about sisters of quiet mercy I
didn't know they posted that promo so I
still can't comment on that but there
you go um Veronica Leon are you dressed
like Betty yes I am Branca I am giving a
little bit of an homage to miss Betty
Cooper I've got my little Peter Pan
shirt and my ponytail with a little pouf
thank you for noticing do you guys like
when I dress up for the episodes I'm not
quite sure I
think it's fine you tell me Judith said
I freaked out today when Roberto posted
a photo with the tombstone with Betty
and Alice's names and if you zoomed in
you saw Daryl Dilton what does this mean
you zoomed in on a very important fact
and so when you watch tonight's episode
you're gonna be very proud of yourself
okay autumn says do you think Archie
will get to leave the bunker without
sneaking around anytime soon talisha
says do you think that Betty will get
pregnant this season no I don't know but
I hope not Katie says do you know if the
farm is where Archie goes is it the farm
I hope not the farm seems insane I want
him to stay far away from the farm I
want everyone to go away from the farm
although I really do like Evelyn ever
never I think she's I think she I get a
big kick out of her I think she's a
great actress and I enjoy her like
really intense eyes Oh everyone's saying
yes the promos out I still can't comment
it on it so enjoy that promo for next
week's episode
Allie says do you think that Ethel is
one of the disciples or do you think
that the people of the farm are the
disciples here's my thing about the
season and about Griffin's and gargoyles
in this whole situation
there are so many rules and layers to
this game that they keep just adding in
more and more and unless by the end of
the season they give a full breakdown as
to how this game works what the
disciples are with this new gang of
gargoyles is like if I don't get answers
to every single one I'm going to be
really bothered so I like that they keep
adding in all these layers but unless
they're going to answer every single
layer that they add I don't need any
more of it Riverdale Bay says what's
going on with bug head cuz Betty seems
hella pissed but she knows he's not in
his right mind I think she just gets him
and knows that his way of doing his
detective work is to really get into the
mindset of the game and approach it from
that end and she's staying more logical
but I think that she's there for him and
they have some really sweet moments in
this week's episode so get excited for
that Lydia says do you think maybe Betty
will have a surprising encounter with
the gargoyle king in this episode and is
so surprised at the end that she ends up
having to go to sisters of quiet mercy
we did see that the gargoyle king is in
their house so I'll leave it at that and
Abby says I think FL has something to do
with the gargoyle stuff because nothing
else ever happened after she talked to
the gargoyle King in the hospital she
definitely has something going on I have
no idea what it is I also don't know
where Ethel is but what I don't even
know what do you guys like the gargoyle
King I like him better than the black
hood I just don't know how I feel about
this & Hedges says will we get more
Everly in this episode there is a line
from Evelyn from Evelyn but just one
it's a good one it's just one doesn't
mean much it's just one and then we've
got time for just a couple more
questions
Zoe says do you think we'll see the
parents talking to each other about
their past yes I do I do think that we
will see the parents talking to each
other maybe perhaps all in the same room
maybe perhaps in this week's episode
maybe they're all really attractive they
are and we've got just a couple more
amber says I think Archie is going up
North because Jughead said he should
escape up north in Episode one of the
season yeah I don't know where he's
gonna go um I don't know what's north I
don't know where Riverdale is I don't
know what the actual date of Riverdale
is there are so many questions but
someone did comment to me on Twitter and
said we don't know necessarily that it's
2018 and I want to count her back and
say then why is it that in the speakeasy
we saw Cheryl instagramming Veronica I
feel like that proves that they're
pretty much within the same timeframe
they just have like old elements and old
nods and lastly oh that's a good one to
end on Carolina says what do you think
the gargoyle King is I have no idea I'm
just I the more I think about the
gargoyle King and the fact that someone
is running around in the woods I said
this in last week's episode with a mask
on and like holding twigs underneath
like a black sheet that they got from
like Bed Bath and Beyond and they're
just like this is it
like this is what
this is and everyone is like bowing down
to this person like
kudos Riverdale riders I don't know how
you come up with this stuff but going
good on you I I hope that when I'm at
comic-con this year I see some girl okay
sorry we're gonna end it here you guys
left so many great comments I hope that
my babbling made sense to you I just
want to say I truly do adore you river
babe so much making these episodes each
week is a lot for me for my crew from my
editor and we really appreciate all of
your comments you guys flood all of our
comments you've made this the most
watched show on et's youtube channel so
since i'm live with you right now
I just want to say thank you and then
check back with me tomorrow after you've
watched 3:06 for our aftershow cuz
you're gonna have a lot of questions I
have a lot of questions we'll try and
figure it all out together if you guys
have had fun with me right now please
give this video a like and then hit
subscribe so you never miss an episode
of Sweetwater secrets and then slide on
down to the comments and tell me how
you're feeling about where this Jean
Gees story is going do you prefer the
black hood plot of season two do you
think Betty would make a badass which in
which couple do you think deserves more
screen time in the future tell me your
thoughts and I'll kiss you later river
babes
[Music]